après avoir rejeté une proposition de
trêve humanitaire de sept jours dans la
bande de gaza israël a finalement
accepté un cessez le feu de 12h et
commencera 7 heures demain matin heure
d'israël et joyce est ce qu'on peut
parler d'une petite lueur d'espoir après
18 jours d'hostilités pour le moins
sanglante eh bien je pense que le mot à
retenir brigitte ces petites lueurs
parce que 12 heures vous le savez vous
en conviendrez avec moi ce n'est pas
très long donc une trêve de 12 heures
qui commence à minuit notre heure il te
reste terminer à midi est ce que c'est a
suffisamment de temps pour pour que
demain cette réunion internationale à
paris donc qui va rassembler le les
britanniques les allemands les italiens
l'union européenne la turquie les états
unis pour voir si on peut pas essayer de
désamorcer cette crise on sait que le
secrétaire général de l'onu et le
sécrétaire d'état américains sont tous
les deux dans la région ils essayent de
décrocher un un cessez le feu on cherche
maintenant brigitte il faut le souligner
un cessez le feu dix humanitaires de
cinq à sept jours justement pour faire
baisser la pression
israël a dit rejeté une première
proposition de cessez-le-feu aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle ait fait dit la presse
israélien trop favorable au hamas on
sait que le hamas refuse pour sa part
toute trêve avant la levée du blocus de
gaza bien sûr le but d'une entente d'une
trêve c'est justement de relâcher un peu
cette pression et d'essayer d'en arriver
à une entente est de faire baisser aussi
cette violence qui dure depuis presque
plus de deux semaines violences
meurtrières le temps presse d'ailleurs
parce que les violences s'intensifient
maintenant en cisjordanie exactement
alors aujourd'hui il ya eu une
manifestation de solidarité en
cisjordanie cent mille palestiniens
bien sûr qu'ils appuient les
palestiniens de gaza se sont rendus un
point de passage israélien
il ya eu des cocktails molotov de lancer
dit on de la part des manifestants
bon des lanceurs de pierres palestiniens
l'armée israélienne a répondu par des
tirs réels il ya eu des blessés des
morts là aussi c'est une situation
d'autant plus complexe que yao
finalement deux territoires palestiniens
donc d'une part vous avez la cisjordanie
entouré de semur qu'a construit israël
et de l'autre vous avez gaza qui est
sous le coup de ce blocus israélien
depuis sept ans deux territoires qui
sont pas contigus et qui se touchent pas
dont vous avez à toutes fins pratiques 2
palestine ce qui rend toute négociation
d'autant plus complexe et compliqué
comme vous êtes merci joyce avoir à voir